My guest this week is Kelly Carlin,
daughter of the legendary comedian
George Carlin.
Kelly is an author and a speaker who's
work connects many of the dots her
father's life was all about.
I've known Kelly for about four years
now after connecting with her on twitter
because of how much I admired her dad,
we become great friends.
Kelly is welcomed me into her world and
the comedy community She's part of here
in la.
I thought Kelly would be the perfect
guest this week,
not only because of her new book about
growing up as a Carlin,
but also because of all the issues her
father's comedy was about that it
becomes central themes of what we do
here on this show.
George Carlin was a relentless defender
of free speech using words and language
to push the limits of what society found
acceptable at the time he railed against
political correctness.
Like no other comment before or anybody
since he dissected the absurdities of
life that ultimately bring us together
rather than rip us apart.
I can't tell you how often I'm watching
some campaign nonsense or some
ridiculous politically correct crusade
and think,
man,
I wish George Carlin was still alive to
tackle this.
Not only do I want you to see George
Carlin in a new way by sitting down with
Kelly,
but I also want to use our chat as a
living,
breathing example of something else
that's going on here.
As I mentioned,
Kelly and I met on twitter.
All I was to her was another person
tweeting at her in 140 characters who
had some connection to her father,
like millions of other people,
but through social media we met,
we became friends,
and now we share so much of our lives
and our passions together.
To me,
that's what's so cool about what's
happening here with you guys.
The reaction to what we're doing has
gotten to a whole new level.
I've been getting emails from literally
all over the world,
from Denmark to Saudi Arabia to Mexico.
We're connecting because of the same
ideas that George believed in,
which I believe in and which you believe
in.
By the way,
that doesn't mean that we agree on
everything actually,
in almost every email I get that's
heaping praise on me.
You guys managed to tell me something
that we disagree on.
I love that.
That's what this is all about and it's
precisely what the far right and the
regressive left fear.
If the rest of us can wake up and
realize that we can come together
despite differences,
then they can't control us.
It's really as simple as that.
The authoritarians that exist on both
sides want control,
and the best way to do that is to keep
everyone hating on each other all the
time.
For all the things that Milo
Yiannopoulos and I disagreed on,
this is one spot we had total agreement.
The rise of the Cultural Libertarians is
here and it contains people from all
over the cultural map,
from Chris Rock to Bill Maher,
from marginalized to Sam Harris.
If George Carlin was still around,
I think he would fit right in there,
but it would have also been shared to
make fun of any group that would have
accepted him as part of it.
The point of all this is that every week
actually,
every day that I've been doing this
show,
I see this movement getting stronger.
You guys are not only connecting with me
but with each other,
and now when I see the usual regressive
spout off their nonsense,
there's an army of people calling them
out on it.
That is literally as important as
anything that I do.
George Carlin's most famous routine was
the seven dirty words.
You can't say on TV.
We live
in a time that's getting dangerously
close to the several dirty ideas that
you can't challenge publicly.
Let's honor the trailblazers before us,
like George Carlin,
by relentlessly challenging and
ruthlessly mocking those who would
attempt to silence us.
Alright,
let's do a show.
My guest this week is an author,
a speaker,
and a one woman show or something,
right?
Her new book,
a Carlin home companion tells her
journey growing up as the daughter of
George and Brenda Carla,
and she's also my friend and throws a
hell of a party.
Kelly,
Carla,
and welcome to the show.
I'm so excited to be here.
This is so fabulous.
Doesn't it seem more mature than
anything we've done?
We've grown up right now.
This is kind of scaring me.
This is very grown up.
Before we start,
you just pointed to our window at this
picture in case now I know we're,
we're blowing the illusion television,
but that is a picture.
It's not an actual window that is,
uh,
the upper west side that's 89th street
facing north and just a little bit past
where this picture ends is actually just
in the last year a street that is now
named after your father.
This isn't where I was intending to
start with,
but let,
let's start there.
Your Dad now is a street,
has officially a street a at 121st and
Amsterdam.
We wanted it to be between Broadway and
Amsterdam,
but there's.
And that was the block he grew up on,
but there's also a church there.
The church,
his mother attended the church that they
had,
the school that he attended as a child.
He was kicked out of that church,
right?
Wasn't where he was kicked out of the
school,
let take down to the school.
And then he was allowed to come back to
graduate for eighth grade,
but he had to write the play in order to
get back in which they were great.
It was actually a very progressive
school for a Catholic school.
Um,
but the irony is,
is that once we wanted to name the
street,
the church,
I'm a got all up in arms about it,
a worried well,
they claimed that they were worried
about kids coming out of school and
looking up and seeing the name and then
googling it and finding out about the
seven dirty words that was their
concern.
Also,
not a huge fan of religion,
never more worried about the religion is
bullshit video that they would probably
find on youtube video.
There must be 50 of them.
There is probably as a.
we're working on that.
We're trying to,
you know,
organize all of that.
But,
but yeah,
but you can go to 121st and Amsterdam on
the other side of the street.
And uh,
there is a George Carlin way,
so just to be clear,
they live so it's on the same street
street,
but they just pushed it one block,
they just put it across the street on
Amsterdam because I mean it's,
it's,
once again,
it's just the thing that churches have
these lines that they draw and they're
ridiculous.
But the good news is,
is that when all this went down was it
got us so much press that it ended up
being like a kind of a funny thing.
They actually got us more attention for
the street sign that I think they
probably would have wanted,
although every comic in the world wanted
to be there that day.
And you had a Zillion zillion amazing
day.
And Kevin Bartini the comic.
He's the one who initiated it and did it
all.
But Yeah,
we had Colin Quinn and Dave attell and
I'm just,
you know,
it was,
it was a great day.
Well,
I love the fact that what I'm putting
right here,
this,
we did this because I used to live on
the upper west side.
So it's a nice.
It's a nice way to feel at home.
Yeah,
so as I said in my intro,
one of the things that I that I love
about having you here,
and we've been doing this kind of stuff
forever,
but one of the reasons that I think is
particularly apropos now beyond just
your book is that all of the things that
your dad stood for,
I think are really coming to fruition
right now.
There's something again,
right?
It's a cyclical thing.
Yeah.
It's like this endless thing,
but I feel like there's a moment now
between religion and political
correctness and free speech,
these things that he railed on more than
anybody and did better than anybody.
They're all coming back right now.
So before we get into that,
let's let's do something a little bit.
We'll give them a little hint from the
book.
Give me something about your dad on,
on the private side,
because this is someone who talked about
culture,
not necessarily talked about himself,
so let's just do a little of that.
He,
he was one of those comics which really
didn't come to me until he died,
really?
But that who really did focus on,
I mean he focused on,
he talked about three things,
you focused on the little things that we
all share.
So that was the observational humor
stuff in the refrigerator man and the
airline announcements and things like
that.
He focused on language,
which is another thing that we all share
as a culture and then he like would go
after the big subjects,
death,
religion,
children,
things like that.
Um,
but he never,
he mentioned me once in a routine in
like 1971,
one of the earlier albums where I was
very excited.
He was talking about,
um,
what's a euphemism for Shit,
you know,
we call it number two and P as number
one and how once I figured that out,
I made funny combinations up and things
like that.
And that was the only time I was ever
taught about.
And for comics,
you know,
99 percent of the time,
their material is their family and their
personal life.
So,
um,
my dad was very different than that and
he didn't.
And he wrote a memoir,
but we didn't publish it until we
published it.
After he died,
so,
um,
what do you think that was,
was about because he's so got into the
mind.
He so got into the very bit of us that
we all share.
And yet that part he did.
Was that respect maybe to your mom or to
your family or.
I don't know.
I think,
I think his mind just didn't travel
there.
His mind was out here and that's just
the way his focus was.
And uh,
so it was kind of weird because I would,
growing up I would see other comedians
about their families and it did hit me a
few times,
especially like teenagers.
Like why Sydney ever talk about us on
like the tonight show.
I remember one time he went on the
tonight show with Carson as the host and
Carson asked about his family and he had
these funny made up sons that he talked
about dark dot Gagnon was one of them,
which I mean it was a great bit,
but I just feel,
I already know I've already felt a
little invisible.
Therefore I felt even a little more
invisible at that time.
And yet I think I'm happy about it
because I wasn't,
my life wasn't fodder for his comedy,
whereas my poor dad,
our life together has become fodder for
my art series a,
which was a bone of contention for us.
Uh,
and I,
and I do talk about that in the book
and,
and not so much as artists,
but that there were some things that we
had never talked about as a family that
I really was willing to talk about on
stage.
Like people like spalding gray and um,
uh,
you know,
Sandra Tsing Loh and these other solo
artists did,
uh,
you know,
they go out and comedians.
I mean,
I think a lot of comedians are way more
comfortable going on stage talking about
their life there than having to go home
and having a serious conversation with
their loved ones.
Yeah.
Well,
we'll get to the sad clown thing.
It'll look to address that.
You do address that in your one woman
show that was sort of a lead up to the
book that there there's a sort of
beautiful moment where you and your dad
are talking and he sort of,
there was like a little bit of sense of
betrayal or a sense that he was going to
be exposed in a way that he had an done
and I think ultimately,
I mean what happened was I wrote a solo
show and I sent him the script and
inside the script I talked about having
some feelings,
some negative feelings about when my
mother was dying and he had to go on the
road and it was a conversation my dad
and I had never had and we didn't have
any real healthy conversation closure
around it.
But,
and I,
looking back on it now,
I think sending him that script was my
way of saying,
hey,
I have these feelings,
but this was one of the themes I wanted
to work on in the book was that here's
this man who is the truth teller.
Like you said at opening of the show.
I mean,
this is the man who conquered everything
was fearless and we'll talk about all
the big stuff that our culture does not
want to talk about on stage.
And yet when it came to our family,
we were very much the textbook,
dysfunctional alcoholic family that did
a lot of walking on eggshells,
didn't do a lot of intimate talking
about the issues and we all pretended
that we were fine.
You know,
we all worked for the American family
truly.
And that's.
And that's like when people talk about
my book and they're like,
oh,
you have such a unique life.
I'm like,
yeah,
not.
I mean I did,
but kind of like the all American
family.
Yeah.
So I don't want to delve too deep
because I want people.
I want people to buy the books,
of course.
So that.
So that's an important piece of this.
But just one more thing on that.
Um,
did you have a sense when you were
growing up,
you know,
your dad,
look,
there were,
there were drug things that you talked
about in the book and in the show
arrests,
you know,
he was,
he was arrested that night that Lenny
Bruce was arrested.
Right?
And is that.
Yeah,
that was before I was born.
But these types of things that were
going on,
he was on the front lines.
So how much of that do you,
were you conscious,
especially in your early years that your
dad really was this,
this legend?
I mean,
when you,
when there's the Mount Rushmore of
comedy,
it's,
you know,
half the people say it's your dad.
Half the people say it's prior and then
maybe there's one percent that gets
split amongst lenny bruce and a couple
of years,
the legend kind of route mount rushmore
thing really happened more when I was in
my twenties.
And uh,
I was at a,
uh,
an English class at Ucla and my
professor says,
you know,
we're going to study a compare and
contrast essays today.
And I have a perfect example of,
of how you should go about this,
and he pushes the play button on a
boombox and my dad's baseball,
football routine comes out and I'm
sitting there in this class of like 25
people looking around going,
um,
is anyone else
having this weird experience?
Are you going to play any shit from
anyone else's dad?
Maybe that's when you realize,
oh yeah,
big dent in the culture has happened
here.
Um,
so,
you know,
I think it was from that point on that I
knew like legend,
but even before that I knew that he was
obviously famous and people worshiped
him and,
and all that kind of stuff and was
around for,
you know,
an arrest or two of his also.
So I knew he was definitely on the front
lines of something.
So let's get into some of the,
some of the themes that,
as I said,
I have become the central themes of,
of what I'm trying to do here,
because you're,
you know,
I say to you all the time,
as I said in the Intro,
I'm watching the news constantly and I
like either text you sometimes or I'll
call you and be like,
God,
I wish your dad was around because.
Because I can't do it.
That can certainly.
And I don't know anyone else that can,
that can skewer stuff in that way.
So let's just hit a couple of them.
So the religion one,
so you already mentioned a little bit
about his history with religion.
Was,
was he an atheist?
Did he describe himself in any specific
way?
Right.
He did not use the term atheist.
He felt atheism was as dogmatic as any
other ism out there.
Um,
uh,
you know,
lately I've been introduced to what they
call the humanist,
uh,
you know,
kind of community,
which is something I relate to a lot
more.
I think he would have felt better about
that.
It sounds like they're not going to have
as many meetings and armbands and things
like that,
which you used to talk about groups
because it's things less koolaid.
I think he felt any,
you know,
any group of people you get group think,
and then where does the individual
thinking,
you know,
happen in that situation?
So that always worried him.
Uh,
I think he's self,
you know,
named himself mostly as an agnostic.
Um,
obviously didn't believe in the man in
the sky with the beard thing.
It's not like he was thinking of that
was a possibility,
but he had a deep sense of oneness with
the universe.
He loved astronomy.
He loved that idea of looking up and um,
you know,
that feeling you get when you look at me
like,
Jesus,
we're just a speck here.
And yet there's something about that
being a Spec that expands us at the same
time.
So there was something around that.
Um,
he was a man who dropped acid in the
sixties and had some transcendent
experiences about that.
And talk to me about,
um,
being a high and having an experience
where he realized that he really was at
one with everything,
including the old tennis shoe in the
gutter and that he realized that if he
was,
that everything was him and he was
everything.
And from that moment on he said he felt
safe because he knew that no matter what
he encountered in life,
he was only encountering a version of
himself.
So that's,
that's pretty spiritual stuff.
That's.
Yeah.
I mean you can put it under,
in that box spiritual.
Um,
and you could,
you could talk about it from a brain
science way and say,
okay,
maybe there's things in the brain that
makes us feel that way or whatever it
is.
But it is an experience that changes
your world view and changes how you
encounter your life and other people,
you know.
And,
and I think that did that for him.
Do you think a lot of his.
Sort of.
Because when I think of it,
I think of this sort of anti religion,
the rants that he would go on at the
church and religion.
And how much of it was just not even
about religion specifically,
but just about authoritarianism or was
that really what it was about?
It wasn't about religion.
Well,
I can't say I won't speak for him and I
don't really know at all what motivated
him to do those bits.
I never was privy to that part of his
process.
How he would sit me down during the Hbo
Taping and let me see it just the way
everyone else saw it.
I never knew his process,
but sure.
I mean,
I think if you looked at all of his
material and and sifted through it and
analyzed it,
I think authoritarian is.
It would be a huge aspect to it all that
anyone out.
I mean he,
my dad never made it through a single
institution encounter.
He got kicked out of everything.
Elementary School,
junior high,
high school did not finish high school.
Ninth Grade Dropout.
Then joined the air force early,
promoted and demoted.
I got a little piece of paper of his
that has all the listings of the
promotions and the emotions that he had
in the air force.
So he got kicked out of that and then
ultimately,
you know,
became this straight suit,
clean cut comic and even that
conservative form that he had to be in,
in order to be a successful comedy
because his dream is to be in the movies
eventually that felt,
you know,
too restrictive and authoritarian for
him and he rebelled against that to
ultimately he was always looking.
I mean,
he talked about the line.
He always,
you know,
a comics job is to find the line and
across it.
And I think that's what that's about is
anyone telling you you can't do
something.
All right,
let's cross it and really see what we
can do on the other side of that.
So let's just back up for a second,
because you mentioned that at one time
your dad was this sort of.
It wasn't conservative comic,
but he was,
he was buttoned down,
get kind of.
He was sort of like everyone else in
this.
He was that generic,
whatever that were,
but then had a moment that it all
changed.
Do you,
do you know what it was personally at
that moment or was it purely like lsd?
It was.
So,
it was the drug.
I mean,
here's the deal on the inside.
He was already the other person.
He had been smoking weed since he was
14.
His politics were a little more
conservative growing up.
His mom was a Republican,
as you know,
whatever they call it,
snow,
anything anymore rela relative to fiscal
because what every school.
Conservatives central liberal,
right.
Exactly.
Um,
and when he met Jack Burns,
his first thing was he was a comedy duo
with Jack Burns.
Jack Burns was left progressive and my
dad was more moderate guy and Jack took
him and pulled him and taught him about
everything.
And then of course Lenny Bruce,
you know,
blew his mind too.
So on the inside,
dad was a radical.
He was hanging out with musicians in the
village,
you know,
he was,
he was one of them,
but he had to put on this exterior in
order to build this career because in
his mind he really did.
He had this Danny k plan and he wanted
to be like Danny Kaye in the movies and
he felt the way to do that was tv and
these night clubs.
I mean really,
there were no comedy clubs back then.
You were doing the playboy club with a
Copa Cabana and you were opening for,
you know,
God knows four seasons was.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
he were lucky.
It was a foreseeable bird.
Humperdink.
Yeah.
I mean he opened for the supremes and
Las Vegas and 69,
you know,
it's like the,
some really think how crazy that is.
Like you can say it and we don't really
absorb what that means.
But your dad.
Yeah.
Even before his transformation opening.
Supremes.
It seems so bizarre.
Yeah.
And that was a,
that was a great gig for him.
He was making a lot of money in that
Gig.
I think you tell a story where he
actually got fired from there.
He got fired for that Gig.
Yeah.
He was making more money than he ever
had made.
And he said the word,
uh,
what was it?
His ass in that one or shit,
I think you said Shit that he got fired
twice in Vegas after shit.
Her Shit and Redd Foxx is down the
street doing triple x stuff of course.
So,
you know,
but,
but this was the thing he realized he
was entertaining the parents of the
people that he was hanging out with and,
and,
and here's like another part of his
outsider status to was he was 30 in
1967,
so he was already too old for the
hippies and all the kids that were going
through that because they were all early
twenties,
but he wasn't relating to their parents
either.
So he was this interesting bridge
between those two generations,
but related obviously much more to the
younger generation.
Let's talk a little bit about,
about language because we've been doing
a ton on political correctness.
Your Dad was not only the most
unpolitically correct person,
but,
but hated it with a passion.
Yeah,
right.
He really hated it and used words in a
way to show us how silly we are being
about things all the time.
And I think right now we're in this very
bizarre place in our country where we're
afraid of certain words were afraid of
offending people.
You talked about the line before and
pushing the limits and like jumping over
the line,
what do you think he would make of
what's going on in this country right
now with,
with words?
Well,
I'm talking about that.
I think he would make what he,
what he's always made it.
But I mean,
in the early nineties this was going on
in colleges too.
I was at Ucla and actually did a,
a forum on political correctness and
invited my dad to come in and do that.
And um,
that was coming out of the Reagan era,
you know,
so there was a lot of that.
But,
but if you really think about it like
political correctness,
there's something about like polite
society,
like we're not allowed to talk about
certain things,
you know,
I think it kind of grows out of that.
But,
you know,
for him,
uh,
he was always bothered by the fact that
it,
it comes from a place of people wanting,
you know,
respect for tolerance,
of,
of each other and our identities.
So it's sort of well intentioned.
It's very well intentioned.
And my dad grew up in Harlem,
but he grew up in Harlem,
a Irish,
White Harlem,
right next to black and Spanish Harlem.
Yes,
he would've called it Black Harlem.
And um,
and that doesn't make him race.
It does not make him racist.
And uh,
and so he very much identified with the
black experience,
the outsider experience and growing up,
uh,
the n word was never ever said in our
house.
And my dad told me it is the one word.
I mean,
I was allowed to say any of the words.
You can say all seven for TV,
but say them in,
in right the right places.
He didn't want me getting in trouble at
school and other people's houses,
but the n word was one where that was
Kelly never,
ever,
ever.
So he got the whole idea of people
wanting to define themselves and having
their own identity.
That's a very important thing and it's,
I think it's an important part of
evolution of our species,
but when you do it by not tolerating
other speech and suppressing language
and speech,
I don't think he believed that that was
not the route to go about this,
that,
you know,
using intolerance to increase tolerance.
It just some to something it just made,
does it fit or something,
you know,
and you know what,
here's the thing about speech and our
country.
I mean,
if you're,
if anyone's under the first amendment,
it's always that old thing that,
you know,
that thing.
It's always a balance between two
forces,
you know.
And so here we are,
we're,
it's about freedom versus sensitivity.
Both things are important,
really important.
Um,
but uh,
you can't throw the baby out with the
bathwater,
right?
I,
I would argue that freedom is a little
more important than sensitivity,
right?
Well,
for you it is for some other people it
isn't,
you know,
but this is the great thing about a
democracy is,
and the way we work this stuff out is by
having free speech and a marketplace of
ideas.
So therefore,
if you're trying to control people's
speech,
then are you really having a marketplace
of ideas and we're not talking about
people bullying people and insult comics
and comics who want to hurt feelings or
you know,
uh,
the whole rape thing that went down.
I mean,
there is obviously we're not talking
about hate speech,
we're not talking about hate speech.
Exactly.
But the thing is my,
you know,
my dad did talk about is that um,
standup comedy is a monologue.
It's not a conversation,
it's an art form that it's a monologue.
It was his bully pulpit.
He used to say,
the Adi,
I'm here for me and the audiences here
for me,
he wasn't here for them.
He's not there to do a seminar.
And he's not.
Even though he was professed sorial,
he was not there to change the world in
some way.
He was there to get shit off of his
chest and he did it in a certain way and
so I would love to know his new take on
all this college stuff and all this
stuff going down,
but I think it would be built on a lot
of this stuff right now with this whole
thing we have on college campuses with
social justice warriors and safe rooms
and trigger warnings.
Things we've talked about.
You wrote an interesting piece about
this on your facebook page that was
related to comedy and all of this and a
little bit it was sort of about your
dad,
but we jumped off because of Jerry
seinfeld making a comment.
Yeah.
And Todd and todd glass had written a,
a,
a reply to a piece in the La Times and
he felt,
you know,
he was kind of on the other side of it,
of respecting people's rights to define
themselves more and you know,
and I just,
I just kind of.
I'd finally,
after I think,
you know,
about a year and a half or two years of
trying to think about all this had
pulled all my thoughts together and,
and,
and some of it I've already shared here,
but the whole trigger warning thing,
I mean I really would have loved my dad
to unpack the,
just the phrase trigger just to help us
unpack it a little bit and I can only
imagine who he would have pissed off
with that I'm sure it would have been
the feminists and my dad was a
considered himself a feminist.
I mean,
you know,
that was the irony,
right?
So something like that,
he would have pissed off the feminists,
but he was very pro woman actually.
Yeah.
He did.
Was To empower women who've never.
He would really talk about something.
Yeah.
His humor for the most part I would say
is very pro woman.
And um,
but I mean,
even when he talked about using the term
rape,
you know,
and it can rape ever be funny.
And then he tells this joke about,
you know,
uh,
donald or daffy duck fucking elmer fudd
or something.
It's funny,
it's a great image.
You can't help but laugh.
So that's gay duck rape.
I'm sorry.
That's pretty funny.
Now I've got the vegans.
Oh Man.
And the game.
Alright,
please trigger warning on that.
That joke right there please.
Yeah.
Uh,
so yeah,
I would.
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
I do like you,
I miss him too.
There are certain things that come up
where I,
where I do.
I'm like,
I wish dad was here and then I'm like,
okay,
so we're going to have to figure this
out on my own or on her own like without
dad how to walk through this,
you know,
and there's some comics out there who I
think definitely helped with this.
Absolutely.
The work is helping.
I was going to ask you that a little
closer to the end,
but as long as I think Bill Maher is,
I think Lewis Black is a,
I think Louis Ck is doing brilliant
work.
I think Amy Schumer is doing great work.
I'm Nora Dunn.
Just went after her today and uh,
because she's talking about using,
naming her body parts,
using nasty words to name her body parts
and she thinks it's self shaming.
So that's gonna be an interesting
conversation between the feminists.
What's going on with that?
Um,
and,
you know,
and I,
and there's a ton of younger comics too
that are doing great work.
Um,
and not that Amy Schumer isn't 1:30
or so young,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's good work going on at there.
Chris Rock,
you know,
always does great work.
So,
um,
you know,
they're out there pushing,
pushing,
pushing the edge,
but the line,
they should be.
So last thought on the,
on the free speech and the political
correctness stuff,
uh,
is,
is this where we could really teach
younger people.
And I hate to say that as if.
I mean,
if there's an arrogance in that too.
I think generations come up and they've
got their own worldview.
They've got their own life experience.
They're trying to define themselves.
Um,
but yes,
I think they weren't around for the
fights.
They weren't around for Lenny Bruce
Getting arrested.
They weren't around for my dad getting
arrested.
They don't understand the luxury.
They have a around free speech and um,
this regressive left.
I guess that's what we're calling them
now.
I had,
I saw one of your path,
what I'm calling.
I had to look it up.
I'm like,
what exactly does he mean by that?
Now I got it.
I understand it.
And it's these people that would be
attacking your dad with the kids and
it's,
there's an authoritarianism around it.
There's a need to control everything in
order for the world to be comfortable.
And Hey,
you know what,
I get it.
That generation is facing a planet
that's dying,
uh,
an economy that doesn't look very good.
Politics that have stopped working,
our democracy has stopped working.
Um,
I too would want to control things.
And so maybe if you can control people's
language and create a sense of safety,
I mean,
maybe that's what this is about on a
psychological level.
I don't know.
Um,
I,
I get it,
but yeah,
I think it is our job to at least bring
some history up and educate them about
the fights we've had in this country to
end to understand what the purpose of
free speeches and it's not like enter
government is no longer censoring.
Yes.
This is the,
it's now corporate America and these
interest groups,
you know.
So did you ever think or or someone.
So your father literally arrested by
because of exercising his free speech.
This is someone who last gigs because of
using pretty mundane curse words.
Do you think he could have ever imagined
if you would agree with what you just
said,
that you would fear the lack of free
speech?
Not because the government is coming
down,
which is so funny.
We're doing it to ourselves.
Do you think he could have ever
envisioned,
envisioned?
He had a lot to say about business and
corporations.
I mean he really hated all of them.
They are the,
they are the owners of this country and
have been ever since the industrial age
began.
What was that bit and his last Hbo
Special About The true owners?
I don't think so.
I think it was the second to last one.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean he would have a lot to say about
that and he,
I mean,
it's not like,
you know,
10 years ago corporations weren't trying
to shave him at advertising dollars,
shape everything on television.
I mean,
now with the Internet,
it's interesting because we have a lot
more freedom,
you know,
and,
uh,
you know,
and I look at like the bigger picture
of,
and you think of like the expansion of
the freedom that the Internet has given
us.
So it's not strange that some other part
of our culture wants to shut something
down.
You know,
there's this,
there is a balance like this all the
time,
you know,
whether it's in our own individual
psyches are the collective psyche.
So it's fascinating.
And ultimately,
you know what I tell people when people
say,
Oh,
your dad,
I wish you know.
And I'm like,
yes,
I get it.
And then I'm going to try not to say to
you,
yeah,
but it's true and I.
But I remind people,
I say,
look,
no matter what,
we can remember this dad said,
when you're born,
you get a ticket to the freak show and
when you're born in America,
you get a front row seat.
So we're at the freak show and then he
added later on another thing which I
love,
which is,
and some of us get to sit on the side
and take notes and talk about it,
which is what we get to do.
So,
you know,
which is a really privileged position to
be in.
Um,
but now everyone gets that privileged
position because it's the internet and
there's comments sector going on,
right?
Twitter,
they're pretty good to me.
They're the people watching this.
Me Too.
We've cultivated something nice here.
So the political situation we have going
on this,
this pathetic really pathetic group of
candidates are pretty much on all
fronts,
in my opinion,
with Bernie being the one exception.
I agree.
Um,
what,
what do you think he would make of this
now?
He did.
He,
he,
he obviously was socially liberal,
but he didn't identify as a Democrat,
did he?
He didn't vote,
but he didn't vote at all,
but he was very progressive.
He always chose people over property.
So,
uh,
whatever candidate chose people over
property,
he would lean towards that.
Uh,
before he died,
he was happy about Hillary back in 2008.
That was,
he was not around for the big Obama
surge and I know he would have been
thrilled to have seen a black president.
I know he would have really been
thrilled about that.
And I got to be in Washington and
November picking up his Mark Twain
Prize.
When Obama flew over,
my husband and I were on the steps of
the Lincoln memorial and Obama was flew
over in the helicopter to go visit
George Bush in the White House for the
first time.
And all I could think about is,
I wish my dad was here right now.
He would have brought a tear to his eye.
Absolutely.
It was a very sentimental man in that
way.
But,
um,
but yeah,
but,
and he saw it all as bullshit as he said
all the time.
He really had a detachment to it.
He didn't vote.
He hadn't voted since mcgovern lost in
[inaudible] 72.
I think that's when his heart really
broke.
Um,
and yeah,
I struggle with that internally,
that he wasn't voting yet.
He was talking so much about this,
but he also felt the system was so
broken almost that it was he would it be
on repairs.
Logic was that you,
if you vote,
you don't have the right to complain if
you
both.
Oh,
that's talk about flipping something on
a test because then you're part of the
problem.
Yes,
completely.
That was his thing and he would,
he'd said that a few times.
It was like,
uh,
but uh,
that was his stance.
So,
and that's where he stood with that and
you know,
he really did.
He was able to compartmentalize and
detach,
like I said,
at home,
rooting for Hillary,
happy that,
you know,
that she was,
shaking things up,
but on stage he didn't need,
would never talk about,
you know,
one way or the other.
I mean like Lewis Black,
you know,
his politics,
you know who he's voting for.
Bill Maher,
he gives money,
like he's tried to get money to burn
money to Bernie on Friday.
He's like,
I want to give you money.
I can only give you $5,400.
You're not taking any super PAC money,
you know,
you have a pre,
you give him another million dollars.
I mean,
Bill Maher literally gave and Obama
super a million dollars budget and it
was sort of brilliant what he said
because he was like,
he's like,
I know this sounds like I'm doing this
for Obama,
but I'm doing this for me because I
don't want the other guy to become
right.
And that's what he was saying Friday
night too.
I was like,
you know,
if you don't like the fish,
eat the chicken people.
What do you think as a comic,
there's a risk in that because then
you've shown your cards too much in that
what your dad did and in a way by,
by holding a little closer.
I think every comic has their own
approach.
It's,
it's as you know that we're all
snowflakes.
Yeah.
Everyone's got their own approach to it
in their own way.
My Dad liked being,
not part of it all.
He liked not being,
having no stake in it,
uh,
so that he could emotionally detached
from it.
I think that's how he personally
protected himself from all of it to um,
I personally don't think that's a
healthy way to go through life.
I love my dad dearly.
I,
you know,
my dad was like,
I gave about the species I gave up on
the planet and I was in my late
thirties,
early forties at the time and I was
like,
well gee,
I hope to have 30 to 40 more years on
the planet.
I'm still kind of involved in the
species a little more and I get the,
you know,
evolution is slow,
but I do believe in the evolution of
consciousness,
you know,
so I try to do my little part.
My Dad,
he was never an activist.
He was never on the front lines,
even in the Vietnam War and all that
kind of stuff.
Meaning had opinions about it,
but he's not a man who got involved.
He onstage did his act,
you know,
activism and there's probably something
to be said for that,
that we all in life,
and I'm not just talking about comics,
but everybody sort of picks very little
role about how they're going to go out
and some people are gonna have kids and
try to teach them the right thing and
people like your dad will have one
child,
but then,
but then teach a generation.
Although he claimed he never.
Although it's not about changing minds,
you know,
uh,
when I used to say please,
really bullshit dad,
like,
come on.
Oh,
he changed me.
He was surreal.
I mean,
that's what he did.
He,
he,
you know,
he had a big stick and he'd come out and
whack us all with it and go,
oh,
we'd all go,
oh shit.
You're right.
Oh,
that's right.
That's the beauty of it is that I agree
ultimately the beauty of comedy more
than anything else,
that when I would watch those specials
from literally from being 12 years old
to being 35,
that I would watch them and go,
God,
this is the truth,
is the truth.
And I don't know how any other comic
where it,
I mean even as his daughter,
I would feel changed in some way by each
of his shows.
There was something in me,
some idea I had about the world had been
stretched in a new way.
Not always a comfortably uncomfortable
way,
but something had been like,
oh,
a little mind expansion had gone on and
I don't know if there are other comics
who do that.
I mean,
I'm entertained by a lot of them.
Um,
it does seem that something in comedy
has changed where counterculture doesn't
seem to be very cool anymore.
Your Dad,
part of the coolest was he was
counterculture.
And right now if you were counter
culture,
it really means you're sort of against
your,
against administration.
So you're somehow you were against Obama
I think maybe because of all this
political correctness stuff,
there's a sense that that's not cool.
So it sort of like the death of.
I don't know,
I think there's still a lot of
independence in that.
Comics have to always are always the
outsider no matter what.
I mean,
even if they vote and they give a
million dollars,
Bill Maher is still going to give Obama
Shit for shit.
I mean,
he's still got his positions,
you know,
and Louis black to given Bernie Shit.
Bill Maher the other day as he was
saying I support.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that really is the
independent thinking and spirit of,
of comedy.
So I think that is,
I really do think that's alive and well.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I spoke about Amy Schumer earlier when I
first saw amy Schumer three or four
years ago,
she was on the Roseanne Roast and I
thought,
Oh really?
Dick Jokes girl,
like,
you know,
we fought so hard,
and you're telling Dick Jokes.
I didn't get it.
I didn't get.
She was playing a persona that she's
kind of pushing up against all of this
stuff and she's doing it in her own way
too.
She's counterculture in some way because
she is taking her.
She's really,
she's,
she's a,
she's a huge feminist and yet she's
taking some of it to task at the same
time.
And,
and I like that.
She makes us a little uncomfortable
around that
stuff.
Well,
we could talk about your dad and all
this stuff forever,
but I want to shift a little bit to sort
of how we know each other past couple of
years and,
and some of the things that we talk
about all the time and you know,
you.
So you have these parties every couple
of weeks at your house where you bring
basically what I would describe as sort
of the wackiest mix of comedians and
actors and writers and philosophers and
who,
what other professions are there behind
the camera.
People,
musicians,
this wild crew of people.
And it's always changing and coming and
going,
uh,
and you call the poly mine.
And so I first want you to explain what
it means to you.
But the reason I love it so much in it
because it's so become part of how I've
treated this show,
that I want my audience to be part of
what we're talking about.
I want it to be a conversation.
So now explain what,
what the poly mind is and most of the
people that you've had at your parties.
By the way,
I've had on previous incarnations my
show.
I bet you,
I mean,
you really like opened up like a zillion
friends to me in the comedy community,
all that
part of the.
I mean,
I love community.
I think being an only child I was a
little.
I was,
I was a loner,
a bit lonely.
So community's always been important to
me and especially in the last 20 years
I've really felt that.
And um,
and,
and part of what happened and how this
came to be was when my dad died,
I became part of the comedy community,
which I was not a part of before and met
Paul prevents and Paul Provenza knows
everybody and he is part of that.
Like he and him and my world kind of
merged in this thing called the what I
call the poly mine commune emerged.
And for me,
the poly mind is,
comes from my,
my roots of studying,
uh,
Carl Jung's psychology,
the collective unconscious that we have
all these archetypes inside of us.
We have all these voices in our head and
they all have a right to have a voice,
you know,
from the most staunch conservative voice
in our head to the most liberal voice,
uh,
to,
to the most immature,
to the most mature.
We all,
everything gets a voice and gets a seat
at the table at some point because every
voice ultimately is important.
Wait,
so let me get this clear.
We're not supposed to shout down the
voices we don't like and we're not
supposed to call them bigots and racists
and homophobic and sexist.
Yeah.
And I think the way,
the reason we do that in public is
because we have such intolerance for the
voices inside of our heads.
Also,
I think what his enter his outer.
I mean,
that's part of what I do.
So part of.
I just love that word.
And so I just came up with this word
poly mind because I really feel like we
all are individually a polyman,
but community in itself is a polyamide
that we each have our own perspectives
and their own way of seeing it in and we
can agree on 10 things.
And then there's four things that we
totally disagree on it.
And that's okay.
We love each other.
Imagine a read on everything.
It will be terrible.
It would be boring and there there's no
learning and expanding and there's no,
you know,
there's,
there's no juice in life at all then,
you know.
So yeah.
So this,
so I just,
you know,
playfully call it the poly mine commune,
because ultimately I'm a Hippie,
you know,
the blues and the weed helps of course
it does test and,
but really it's become um,
what I love,
what happens in these things is that,
like you said,
this cross pollination happens.
And my favorite thing which happens when
I,
you know,
I haven't had a lot of big parties
lately.
I used to have a lot of big parties,
but in the big parties,
maybe 60 people will be at my house and
it always happens that two people will
encounter each other in my kitchen who
have not seen each other in 15 years who
grew up together.
I was something crazy like that.
And there's this re,
uh,
you know,
this reunited reunited and it feels and
um,
and then there's like suddenly they're
collaborating on a thing like three
months later I hear they're
collaborating on a thing.
There's a lot of collaboration going on
and that I don't know,
that just brings me such joy to know
that I can create a space for that stuff
to happen.
It is really good.
Yeah.
And I mean I can give you a living,
breathing example of that as you know,
because Rosanne and I became good
friends and we've been working together
and doing things.
One of the more interesting ones that
happened at your place was,
I guess it was probably about a year
ago,
I met Taylor Negron,
who for those that don't know him was,
he was a brilliant comic actor.
And then stand up really in the eighties
into the nineties,
storytime brilliant,
brilliant guy who I loved without
knowing him.
And then I met him one night at the fire
pit at your place and we were talking
and you know,
I could tell like he thought I was funny
that I got it kind of thing and you
know,
we were talking,
talking and then I told him about my
show and he said he would do my show.
And then literally two months later I
found out he was dead like didn't you?
And I assume he knew he was sick.
I don't know a lot about the story,
but those types of things are what's
going on there.
And that's what was so magical about it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
and people feel comfortable to be
themselves there.
I mean,
that's why Roseanne will come to my
house and I know it's not like I have,
as you know,
there's not like all these a list
celebrities sitting around my fire pit.
It's not like that actually.
But,
um,
every once in a while Roseanne will come
by and she feels comfortable there
because no one's like gawking at her or
whatever.
And um,
but it was like,
I mean,
the first time she came to my house,
it was,
it was one of those moments because even
though I grew up being my dad's daughter
and everything,
these people,
icons to me,
and I'll never forget the first day she
was there,
her and Rick Overton and Paul Provenza,
we're sitting around the fire pit and
I'm walking by with some friends and I'm
like going,
Oh God,
what's going on in my backyard?
And meanwhile you're the daughter of
George Carlin.
So I have no concept of that.
That's just who I am.
So,
yeah,
but,
you know,
and yet this incredible thing starts to
happen.
And like I said,
believe people will start collaborating
and it's,
it's just,
it's beautiful.
And I don't even really bring this up so
that for the purposes of name dropping,
something like that,
as much as that,
there's something really interesting
when you can connect people that care
about the same things.
And that's really what we're trying to
do here and that's what I,
and I think that's the hope of our
species,
is that we can have a safe space for
conversation.
Um,
and you know,
one of the things about the internet,
which is fabulous because we met on
twitter and all of that is great,
but there doesn't feel like there's a
lot of safe space,
you know,
you have to really filter through a lot
of anger and rage and lonely people who
are trying to make a dent in the world
and not do it in a nice way.
I'm not conducive to conversation or
listening.
There's a lot.
There's very little listening going on
on the Internet.
There's a lot of talking going on.
So yes,
uh,
in,
in our lives,
we are trying to create space where we
can hear each other,
you know.
Uh,
well I'm glad you mentioned the online
thing and twitter because one of the
things we talk about all the time is I
don't even have this device.
The device I was going to go into my
pocket.
But fortunately I actually gave it to my
producer before we started.
I don't have it on me.
This is a rare moment that I don't have
my phone on.
Are you reading?
Are you okay?
I'm totally okay.
And we're here,
right?
We're present.
We're here.
We're having a conference.
Not like it's not right.
Yeah.
And so the reason I think we talked
about all the time is because we hate
it.
We and we love it.
I know,
and yet it brought us together and then
at the same time I want to make a living
using it because we find an audience and
we can connect with an audience with it.
I mean,
I found my voice on twitter.
I learned to write a joke because of
twitter and,
and the limit of twitter that go onto me
of words that,
which I think they're planning on
changing.
And I'm like,
no,
I love twitter,
but I told you I'm not going to keep
saying your dad for that.
Um,
but,
but this device and this thing that
we're in this horror,
um,
what are you,
what do you.
To me it's a net win at the end of the
day,
it's the net week,
but it is connected.
So many people.
It's literally helped revolutions in
Egypt.
Um,
and then on the other hand,
I see people's attention spans are being
shredded.
There's no more stories about that.
Neurons in people's brains are firing
differently.
Yeah.
You know,
every two seconds.
And if you're on a street corner meeting
a friend where you might have to stand
there and look up at the sky,
God forbid you're,
you know,
you're liking instagram and you're like,
I don't even like this person,
like all of this stuff.
I think for me,
what's really.
I mean we've talked about this before,
but even on a new level,
just in the last month or so,
I really am starting to get sick of the
intrusiveness of it.
How dare it.
And I say it like it's some sort of
autonomous thing and I haven't invited
it in.
It's not autonomous yet,
but it does kind of feel that way
because it's the part of my brain.
Like I don't feel like I have control
over that part of my brain.
So it is feel like,
and I really feel like if you want to be
the fear is that if you put it away,
you're not going to be part of the
culture that you feel like you're
actually missing.
So you do feel like you're missing
something and you know,
you probably are.
But as you know,
when you and I do our little retreats
that are electronic retreats and we turn
off for a week or 10 days or sometimes a
weekend,
you don't really miss that much,
you know,
that's the thing.
So it goes on.
So right before we launched the show in
September,
I got married the week before in Sonoma
and I've told you this,
but I did 10 days off.
I did not look at my phone for 10 days.
I didn't look at email,
I didn't look at twitter,
I didn't post.
I posted one thing on youtube for 30
seconds just to say I'll be back,
don't.
I wasn't like,
you've been worried about me.
I don't think anyone is entail fitting
care.
I thought they cared,
they didn't.
But I actually,
I genuinely felt my brain resetting.
I felt I've described to you before as
like,
you know,
when you used to turn on an old desktop
computer and there'll be some worrying
and some being being.
And I felt bad.
I actually felt that in my head and then
when I got back I was like,
wow,
everyone's just up to the same old.
Yeah,
same old conversations,
same old annoyances,
same old bitching and moaning.
And yet we're both agreeing it's net
good.
So is that the.
That's the conundrum
I think in and so it really is like
everything else,
it's neutral so it's can be used for
good or evil and like everything else,
you have to be conscious about it.
You have to really decide what are you
using this for in your life and in and
in your career and how much of it,
you know,
what,
there may be an overall net good,
but how much of it is a net negative in
your life and your personal life and in
your process and your creative process?
You know,
I've been finding lately that I'm doing
much better away from it all because I'm
going deep down to try to figure out
what my next book is.
I can't do that when I'm online and I'm
doing,
I'm looking out into the world.
I have to go inside of myself to figure
that stuff out and do some research and
some things,
but I have to be very conscious about
what I'm doing.
Um,
and,
and that's my process and I'm figuring
that out and I think the longer we have
this technology,
I mean you have to think about it in
2008 was the first smartphone.
The first iphone came out.
That's only been seven years.
So as a species,
it's nothing as a culture that's
nothing.
So we are starting to feel the pain of
it and,
and,
and the problems with it and I,
you know,
and I think we're going to start making
some real new decisions about it too.
I'm guessing that,
I mean it's,
I feel like I'm already doing that in my
own personal life.
Yeah.
And not only doing it in your personal
and your professional,
so you do a podcast also where you talk
a lot about sort of waking up and and
the spiritual journey that we're on and
I think all of that is directly related
to this stuff because when we're,
when we're in it,
people are fighting,
people are approved,
giving you an endless approval.
But to me it's like the approval stuff,
which is really nice.
It's nice,
but like that it's like,
oh well I,
I think I'm putting saying good out
there.
So it's nice to be acknowledged.
I don't really dwell on it.
But then you get some negative stuff and
it can,
it can spin you out out.
Tell it days.
And that's what I mean about this.
All this all being live,
this whole thing is actually alive
and yet there's something exciting
about,
you know,
that if we were really to become a
collective,
a conscious collective mind on some
level where we could really solve the
really big problems that we need to
solve.
We need many voices to do that.
I mean,
that's what democracy is about,
this marketplace of ideas and so it
invites that,
you know,
there's this other level of connection
that,
you know,
um,
there's a Pakistani hip hop artists a
deal.
Omar,
who I met also on twitter fan of my dad
because he saw youtube videos.
This kid is 20 something in Pakistan,
hip hop artist.
He was just at my house a few nights
ago.
Um,
that's amazing that he and I connected
in the world on twitter to begin with
once again and now we're friends in real
life.
That's,
there is hope for a species when we can
do stuff like that.
You know,
I,
we sat around the fire pit the other
night and we really asked them,
what's it like there,
what's really going on,
what's the thinking,
what is the Pakistani government really
doing?
You know,
all this stuff.
I got to have that conversation with
someone because of this stuff.
So,
but,
you know,
all of the trolling and all of the
distraction and all of the Click Bait,
I'm,
once again,
it's like anything else,
you either going to let the distraction
distract you because that's what they
all want.
I mean,
you know,
they were the fuck that is.
But um,
ultimately keep us fighting with each
other and then we can't look at the real
problems and try to solve them.
That's okay.
Literally how,
I don't know if you saw in the green
room at the beginning of that's how I
started.
Yeah.
And,
and so therefore we're not really having
the real conversations we should be
having,
but dammit we are because you're here,
you're doing this.
There's a lot of real good conversation
going on in the world now.
But,
but we have to be the grownups and say,
Ya know,
more clickbait.
Sorry,
I'm not,
I'm not doing it,
you know,
and the,
and the ones who are distracted by it,
well there's always going to be mob
mentality.
It's part of the species.
It's how we're wired.
Yeah.
And that's what's so nice about doing
something that I think people are
responding to the way they are because
there's so much crap.
So it's not like there's five things and
they're finding something that they
relate to.
There's a good jillion things and
they're finding some something that's,
that gives them a little sense of
presence or a little center.
Yes,
people are hungry for it.
And I think after this,
you know,
this Internet explosion,
we all had fun being distracted for the
last we all 10 years or whatever.
It's all fun to be distracted.
But now it's also like,
oh,
it's the hottest year again.
Oh,
it's crazy weather.
this shit's really going down.
Oh,
there's no one gonna fucking be sweeping
out of the sky and rescuing us.
Oh,
maybe we do need to get our shit
together.
Maybe we do need to just.
I mean,
it doesn't have to be these serious
heavy as conversations all the time,
but where are the grownups?
I want to go hang out with the grownups
and yes,
smoke some pot and have a nice drink and
laugh and be silly too.
But um,
yeah,
I want to be hanging out with the people
that are kind of trying to think
straight about that.
Well,
that's what we're trying to build here.
I almost feel that that should be the
ending of the show.
But I'm going to give you one more.
I'm going to give you one bonus question
which is what's next?
What's next?
What's this worth?
What is the next after all this,
because I know how much,
how much of you you had to pour into
this book.
I saw the copies before I saw the
manuscript when it was a,
just a printed from your printer and all
that and how much you had to put
yourself into this and go into talking
about things that are scary to talk
about and in and expose your,
not only your dad but your mom in a way
my whole life and your whole life in a
way that people didn't know and you
know,
especially because someone like your dad
where he's held up to this thing and
that you were showing him in a different
light and all that stuff.
Where do you go?
Yeah,
I mean I think there's been kind of two
mes the last 10 years,
the one that's had this book in me and
know that it was unfinished business and
that I had to,
that in some ways it was going to give
me permission to have a bigger
conversation in the world.
And,
and on a personal level it was
unfinished business just around my
psychological healing.
Um,
I mean I am a person who had studied
psychology and I do focus more on the
inner life and the cultural life on,
on some levels,
although I'm pretty 50 slash 50 these
days.
So really I think my next thing is
really pointing my,
my mind slightly more outwards.
You know,
that it'll always be interested in our
personal process and how do we get from
a to B and B to c and C to d.
But I think they're really connected.
I think how we do this on the inside the
micro is connected to the macro and,
and how we treat ourselves is ultimately
how we treat each other and how we treat
the planet.
And so I'm interested in connecting all
of those dots.
I don't know exactly what it looks like
right now,
thinking I'm going to start up my
podcast again.
I'm looking to something a little more
elevated level around the podcast,
maybe with video or something and
finding a new format.
Um,
I've suddenly become the humanist girl I
go to.
I did a keynote speech at the humanist
association,
American Humanist Association conference
last summer.
I was speaking at the reason rally.
I'm speaking at the reason rally and
I've been hired to do another one in May
in Vancouver.
And I'm suddenly like,
I'm the spiritual humanist girl.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it's very interesting.
But there's something about soul and
meaning and the inner life that I think
is important and it's important part of
the conversation and doesn't have to be
thrown out just because we don't believe
the whole church bullshit and religion
of bullshit.
Um,
there's still way to find meaning in
wonder.
I think wonder is a really important
aspect.
If we could get reconnected to the
wonder of being alive,
um,
we'd all
appreciate people a little bit more.
Stop yelling at each other,
yelling at each other.
Right.
You know,
I mean obviously it's not going to
happen,
but I,
but I really believe so and I think we
would really treat our planet a little
better.
So I'm,
I'm kind of want to be in the wonder
business,
whatever that means.
Right.
I did not know that the answer was going
in that direction,
but it's been,
you know,
look,
we've been on this adventure for awhile
and I look forward to seeing what's,
uh,
what's next.
You can follow Kelly and give her all
your approval and disapproval and all of
that good stuff on twitter.
It's at Kelly underscore Carla.
She's got the unders.
I do.
I'm sorry.
I was,
I was a Dork at the beginning of all
this.
I didn't know what was going on.
Got The underscore.
Or you can check out her book,
a Carlin Home Companion,
which you can get pretty much anywhere
books are sold and thanks for watching.
And uh,
now we can go get a drink and do the
other stuff.